con nuestra segunda invitada del día
hablamos de la Nueva Era de la
tecnología cuántica tras conocerse los
ganadores del premio Nobel de física el
día de ayer los científicos Alain John F
closer y anton sellinger nos acompaña
entonces más Romero sala como ya bien lo
estábamos diciendo y también los Angela
García física con phd en astronomía de
swing University of Technology y actual
profesora de la Universidad Nacional de
Colombia gracias a luz Ángela por estar
aquí con nosotros en directo América
Hola Cómo estás Muy bien nos acompaña en
el estudio y pues vamos a poner en
contexto como estos científicos llegaron
a Este descubrimiento no lo que vimos el
día de ayer explicar un poco en lo que
consiste lo que experimentaron Ok pues
La idea es que estos estos tres
científicos plantean un experimento para
explicar cómo se puede digamos que
entender estos
lo primero que tenemos es sistemas
entrelazados sistemas cuánticos
entrelazados que inicialmente Einstein
rosan y polsky
habían planteado en los 30 para como a
una paradoja de cómo la cuántica era una
ciencia de alguna manera incompleta que
nos da una información
completa de un sistema cuántico y pues
ellos lo hacían de alguna manera
intentando como romper con esa con esa
idea de la mecánica cuántica
Einstein no fue particular un gran
seguidor de esta teoría y lo que hacían
era mencionar que habían algunas
variables ocultas o algunas
instrucciones con las cuales se
producían este este tipo de sistemas
entrelazados ya Más adelante se plantea
que si existen estas variables entonces
probablemente
se cumplen unas desigualdades las
desigualdades que plantea John johnbel
en los 60 y lo que vemos en este punto
es que a partir del 69 estos científicos
que ya son galarnados por el premio
Nobel plantean una serie experimentos en
los cuales pueden testear
experimentalmente estas desigualdades de
él estos
digamos que estas estos desarrollos
teóricos y Pues digamos que no solamente
se logra establecer que se violan en las
desigualdades de él que si el sistema es
digamos tiene una correlación tan alta
que en realidad existe un sistema
entrelazado entonces lo que está
ocurriendo es que es la mecánica
cuántica efectivamente si nos da una una
un resultado correcto y
pues además de eso tenemos unas
implicaciones bastante importantes en
cuanto a la computación cuántica y otros
desarrollos luz Ángela yo quería
preguntarle algo no estaba mencionando
precisamente a Einstein no como él había
hecho descrito que estas partículas de
su posibilidad de que estuvieran
entrelazadas no unidas sin ni siquiera
tocarse era ciencia Espeluznante no dijo
Spooky Science Por qué por qué le daba
tanto miedo y que es pues a él y seguro
Aunque a mucha gente no porque la física
cuántica y o esta posibilidad de esta
conexión entre partículas parece tan de
ciencia ficción Bueno hay dos cosas
Einstein en 1905 plantea la posibilidad
de que tengamos
una interacción Y entonces si las
partículas están Están interactuando
pues ellos están afectando en un tiempo
que está definido por una Cota máxima
que es la velocidad de la Luz entonces
por ejemplo si yo veo un objeto pues ese
objeto está emitiendo fotones que llegan
a mis ojos y entonces yo puedo crear una
imagen de de ese objeto Pero eso toma un
tiempo es un tiempo muy corto porque
obviamente la velocidad de la luz es
nuestra nuestra velocidad más alta
conocida pero es un tiempo infinito
Entonces el hecho de que dos objetos
que no están interactuando y que nos
están digamos nos está interactuando en
tiempo real que cuyos estados están
perfectamente bien definidos y pues hoy
en día sabemos que estos estados se
pueden producir a una gran distancia el
experimento en tenerife es un poco más
de 150 kilómetros el hecho de que los
estados estén perfectamente bien
definidos una vez que realizamos la
medición da la sensación o dar la
impresión de que hay una interacción
instantánea lo cual molestaba bastante a
Einstein porque uno de los postulados la
relatividad especial es justamente que
esa interacción no se puede dar de forma
instantánea tiene que estar regulada por
el tiempo que se demora la luz en ir de
un punto a un punto a Entonces eso era
como lo que le resultaba un poco Spooky
un poco como como extraño a Einstein y
sus colaboradores en ese momento
un poco inexplicable no y yo quiero ver
como un poco más allá Yo sé que a lo
mejor no falta muchísimos años pero es
posible mediante esta tecnología
mediante la mecánica cuántica la
teletransportación en un futuro Bueno
hay que decir que lo que logran estos
estos científicos en realidad es
teleportar los estados entonces si yo
tengo dos o más partículas que están
entrelazadas lo que puedo es
transportar ese estado de un punto a un
punto b y una vez que se realiza la
medición entonces yo voy a poder saber
cuál es el estado de la otra partícula
entrelazada pero no es una transferencia
en este momento de materia Entonces
en ese sentido digamos que la
teletransportación no sería exactamente
lo que se busca con ese tipo de
tecnología sino más poder
transferir información o digamos que
portar
aún sin que los sistemas estén
interactuando en digamos localmente
ella quiere viajar teletransportarse
No yo le quería preguntar entonces
precisamente por estos experimentos que
si se están dando no esta transmisión de
la información en qué estamos en la
investigación porque sabemos que el
premio Nobel premia carreras no premia
vida de investigación No es que sea una
descubrimiento súper reciente de este
último año sin embargo se está aplicando
no hablabas del experimento de tenerife
es lograr pues transmitir información a
través de estas partículas entrelazadas
a más de 100 kilómetros creo que 140
kilómetros no Cuáles son los últimos
avances que se están haciendo en
información cuántica hoy en día bueno
estuve revisando ayer y parece ser que
ya las empresas están construyendo vive
m ya tiene un computador cuántico con
120 127 cubetas o
Entonces esto nos permite ver que uno la
carrera hace la computación cuántica
Está avanzando rapidísimo otra cosa
importantísima es que vamos a poder
tener una transmisión de información
mucho más segura
porque esos estados entrelazados una vez
que digamos que se realiza una medición
o se intenta interactuar con estos con
alguna de las dos partes del estado se
rompen entonces si yo estoy enviando
información encriptada y alguien intenta
interceptarla pues Sencillamente voy a
tener inmediatamente que el
entrelazamientos se va a romper Y eso
Por ejemplo puede ser muy interesante si
pensamos en transferencia de información
para la banca para todo tipo de sistemas
donde tengamos que tener información
encriptada y hay una aplicación también
muy interesante que probablemente no
tiene como tanta tanta atención y es la
metrología cuántica sabemos que hay
muchos siste muy pequeños donde no
podemos medir directamente ciertas
propiedades del sistema Campos
magnéticos Campos gravitacionales pero
con esta tecnología en principio se
podría hacer un avance muy grande porque
estamos hablando de sistemas
microscópicos con los cuales vamos a
poder hacer mediciones de forma directa